hi im sue cleaner from chicago i'm
actually a tag-along spell sure what am
I management consultants of a real
person as well this has been a fabulous
conference I just got out of a session
we've done Neil Ferguson that was seen
there actually little frightening to be
honest but the previous one was with a
professor from Australia David
Christiansen and he teaches about the
history of the world which I can't wait
for him to have this website which is
supposed to be operational in 2013 he's
bringing in a history of the world Lee
from the bang through months modern
times to the US and I think Scotland's
using it as well Korea Australia but
what's fascinating about this he's
merging every discipline the world in a
seamless way so that we will all have a
basis to learn from and I think in many
ways this will allow us to be able to
communicate better with each other and
have a stronger understanding of how
science plays a role in our lives a
factual basis but also an artistic way
as well